today we're gonna be trying these
Starbucks holiday drinks we make we got
em all and we basically just like
anything that was sparkly Christmassy
Frosty's yes you not a drink coffee
that's me ro turns up caffeine maybe
like a lot of different menus yeah but
we chose Starbuck Starbuck so only a
great day we were trying to come up with
a corny ranking system and we're gonna
have a nice list and a no cheat list get
it cuz it's not good yeah okay this
looks good there's some artificial
coloring going I don't know I'm trying
to be nice okay at first it tastes just
chocolaty but the aftertaste is mocha oh
I like this a lot oh I'm in trouble this
is probably the worst part about this
video is that I'm gonna discover things
that I actually want to get all the time
I find it kind of refreshing yeah almost
like tiramisu is that there I go I'm in
the spirit yeah this French cheer I have
my concerns about this one
eggnog I am NOT excited but I think it
smells delightful
I love eggnog I'm kind of excited about
this I don't like it and I like eggnog I
like it and I don't like eggnog I'm not
feeling that one it tastes to me like
eggnog that tried but didn't succeed I
don't know if I like it but I think it
has exceeded my expectations which were
quite very low yeah okay and see it
didn't live up to my expectations
because my eggnog expectations are like
not as bad as I thought it was gonna be
however anything I'm still gonna put
this on the night this is peppermint
white chocolate mocha I have faith in
this one's got a little chocolate chip
me too I'm kinda excited about
and that's a lot of effort and that I
like and it tastes like an arrest Minh
this just like a southern church mama's
purse Wow nope that's a lot this is
peppermint mocha frappuccino it's the
same one but without the white chocolate
which scares me because if it's less
ingredients that means even more
peppermint yes
punch okay I don't know if I'm ready the
peppermint is not as strong as that one
I still kind of don't like it I don't
like it either but it I think they did
double the chocolate instead of a half
chocolate half white chocolate which is
better so good this is a toasted white
chocolate cocoa I love this I remember
when white yeah hot chocolate first came
out and I was hanging revolutionary well
I feel like I could get into this I
could get into this really hot what a
piece of pancake oh you a vision I
cannot see past this moment right now
with this on my taste buds this is not
this is a snickerdoodle hot chocolate it
smells like snickerdoodle yeah it tastes
it yeah snickerdoodle flavor is there I
love snickerdoodle cookies yeah James
like snickerdoodle but it tastes like
heavy cream with snickerdoodles what it
tastes like
sounds like a winner to me so what list
is this on I think we can put it on a
nice list okay
there's someone out there who this is
their cup of hot cocoa this is a
peppermint mocha a classic
that tastes like coffee no no if you
like coffee I think this is a good way
to just like sprinkle in some holiday
cheer to your morning routine okay so
this is the eggnog latte oh I just smell
it
why do they keep doing this to eggnog
eggnog I never do nothing to nobody I
don't I'm not a fan do you like it I
want to know who orders this
I'm sure I'm offending somebody out
things like that is my daily routine I'm
sorry I can't wait this is a chestnut
praline latte everything is gonna taste
really like super sweet coffee yeah
which I'm very scared about yeah I'm
liking okay I like coffee so I think I'm
gonna like this mm-hmm
I don't hate it it's almost got like a
cappuccino touch to it
I wouldn't water it but I'm not mad at
it this is definitely nice so this is
the Juniper latte you know part of the
flower right and juniper is a flower
that is right
this smells floral I've definitely
tasted like flowery flower almost makes
me think summer I don't really get
Christmas vibes I'm not mad at this yes
so this is a caramel brulee latte whoa I
like it
I'm I like this there's so much it's
like I feel that happening mm oh yeah
[Music]
wow this is like the flavor is good it's
just like I can't even wrap my brain
around it cause it's like drinking
melted caramel it's on my nightly okay
this is a cinnamon Dolce latte I'm kind
of excited all right let's see how this
is and I like it this almost tastes like
if you mix like a an expressed a latte
and I try to you laugh day I think this
might be an acquired taste I think we
should put it on the nice list because
you like it we already know I don't like
coffee so I'm not really even a fair
judge there so this is a hot version of
our favorite drink so far toasted white
chocolate mocha oh I like that
yeah buddy this is good that's it
peppermint white chocolate mocha we have
legs white chocolate drinks throughout
this endeavor but we haven't liked the
peppermint ones how's that my arms are
kind of shaking yeah I am like there are
full chunks of chocolate this is a
choking hazard sometimes you get one of
those flakes and you're like why is this
better than the frappe first it is it's
not my favorite drink in the world but
it's I don't hate this I can eat all the
nice here it is the last drink which is
good because we're loosen it you don't
like it that's like a melted piece of
chocolate they can't get that peppermint
right to save your life
I see where they're going I see where
they're headed the future is promising
I'll say I'm down for anything holiday
themed it's such a small little window
in the year you have to live it up in
every way you can if that means putting
some holiday cheer and your morning
routine wherever you can get it I say do
it
I didn't love every drink but I don't
think you're supposed to so let us know
what your favorite holiday drink is in
the comments
[Music]